everyone loves a two-for-one deal buy
one get one free is one of the sweetest
phrases in the english language and
nowhere is that more true than in
esports collaterals are getting two
kills with one bullet in first person
shooters are some of the most satisfying
shots in gaming whether it's a lucky
shot or a perfectly timed bullet nothing
feels better than seeing a kill feed
light up with a collat but before we get
started i want to tell you that we have
a new episode of our new show every
second count is brought to you by cisco
and episode three is all about the
craziest comeback and valor in history
so please check it out as soon as you're
done watching this video now without
further ado let's get to the top 10
collateral shots in esports
starting off this list is tens and his
back-to-back collaterals against
immortals it'd be would it be my friend
but now immortals after that last one
are you choking me has tens really does
pull they know they're collateral tens
has shown us time and time again that he
can do some truly incredible things with
the op
but this play should prove that he is a
god just watch these back-to-back
collateral kills against immortals at
the knights gauntlet invitational this
has flipped out of nowhere now sully
tens has to go into a one on two but
again he has that off
he's just so been waiting
ends with the collateral
but remember i said back to back
collapse because the next round tents
did it again
it'd be what it be my friend but now
immortals after that last one are you
choking me has tons really does pull
they know they're collateral the op
magazine has five rounds but tens only
needed four
for our number nine spot we have one of
the most iconic collaterals in esports
history small man one's triple collat
[Music]
oh baby a triple
oh yeah
let me set the stage for you it's modern
warfare 4 free for all on back law and
small man 1 was armed with an m40 and
all the patients in the world
what happened next was history
[Music]
oh baby a triple
oh
and that was my triple collateral on
free-for-all this play is so iconic that
the owner of the upload is trying to
sell it as an nft
if and when it's sold the video which is
sitting at 8.7 million views will be
taken down forever
but this legendary moment will live on
forever
for eighth place we need to go back in
time to see some vintage forest for his
filthy collat against hellraisers as can
often happen
coming in for oh forest that's
disgusting forest is one of the most
beloved players in cs go history and for
good reason he's been slapping kids on
land for over a decade
it's just a great job isn't it 30
seconds again for a one versus four he's
already got the one kill tapping away
and taking down 25 seconds maybe they're
gonna be looking the wrong way but
they're hiding in the corner
now it's a one-on-one makers coming in
he's just out of the bond forest he
needs one more kill we'll win her story
clutch if he could do it grenade landing
on top he's down to 50.
and back at the e-league premiere in
2017 forrest pulled off one of the most
few sit-down plays we have ever seen in
overtime with the scoreline 16 to 16
forest was in a 1v2 and needed to defuse
the bomb but instead of looking for a
more suitable weapon
forrest went full aggro with the op
one nick's been waiting for the rotation
all this time i don't think forrest saw
his opponent through the flames there as
can often happen
coming in for oh forest that's
disgusting i haven't heard many plays
described as grotesque but when you're
casting forest you gotta get creative
seventh place goes to jw's beautiful
collat against sk gaming
all right all right hold on it's like
don't blink don't blink
gw is a pretty underrated offer he's
proven time and time again
that he can be an absolute menace with
the gun it's time
it's time james it's time for
counter-strike again
but i don't get too attached to it oh my
god but during esl pro league season 3
jw really showed his prowess when he
single-handedly put an end to sk's be
execute with some unbelievable flicks
closing out the round with the collat
back in towards b now that boost could
come back to bite them they are
centering are they and they're going to
be nading off and jw of course lands the
first shot they're going to be fully
aware
coming in at number six is reza's
absolutely demoralizing triple kill
collat against g2
what is this
rez is a fantastic all-around player but
he's mostly known for his ability as a
rifler however in season 10 of esl pro
league rez showed that he's not too bad
on the op either when he pulled off this
nutty collat as if that you know this
wasn't hard enough for g2 that nade has
just whittled three players to 50.
uh
what
cracking the top five is the french god
himself it's zye wu and his nutty 3k
collat against dignitas
at iem fall 2021 vitality were pretty
far ahead of dignitas but zymut still
styled on them with this perfect triple
collat and it is back to be they have to
break this set up i do not envy them i
mean it's the adamo
freiburg proves it only for a moment
halser trading
with that triple kill oh baby a triple
look zyru is good but come on that's
insanely lucky
not being the fourth position on our
list is a collateral that defies reality
it's penny and this bizarre shot against
fnatic and actually wait magnum's found
room on vanity that's very surprising
he's just crept on site now penny's a
little baffled what
look valerian is a relatively new game
it's only a year old so there are still
some issues lingering around but even
though we all know there are bugs this
shot is just infuriating
and actually wait magnum's found roman
reality that's very surprising he's just
crept on site now penny's a little
baffled what
somehow penny hit this onto two members
of fnatic even though it wasn't even
close to doma our best guess is that
penny somehow bent the bullet 45 degrees
or something or maybe there are issues
with the network and hitboxes you be the
judge we just thought this one was too
wild not to include
coming in at third place is cadian and
his double collat against renegades
and we said kadia needs some confidence
back and
i don't think he gets much better than
that over the last year kadyan has
proved that he is one of the most
impactful players in the history of cs
go but he's been sick for years
and if you know anything about canadian
you know that he's been dropping bombs
since his days on sk
that's a three
and knock sk down to one life to join
clg
[Music]
well flashes are coming in to be they've
gone with a bit more tempo this time oh
double shot there from canadian
takes down yemen's sponge he was missing
earlier but i suppose he makes up for it
taking two with one bullet there
but they're gonna keep pushing they
still want this b-side there's canyon
again oh my god
two bullets four people for kady and
you've got to give him the ace at this
point
that's right two collats in one round
what makes us play even better is the
fact that sk was on a full save minus
the op cadian had the match ended up
going into overtime and sk won it out
he's already out he's kind of sprayed
towards standing but sanding gets the
better of him and you can see what that
means to sk gaming here finally they
take down renegades
our runner-up award goes to the play
that left everyone speechless
it's oscar and his collateral 3k against
fnatic um we killed the studio
what the hell i broke the network cable
i fixed it facing off against fnatic at
ecs season six oscar had to protect the
bomb in a 4v1
after taking out twist oscar had to find
a way to delay the diffuse but he did
one better
krieg and they have got a kit but
oscar's so good in these situations
um we killed the studio
a triple collat so good he almost
destroyed the broadcast
taking the top spot on our list is the
time device pulled off the most
unbelievable collateral in csgo history
he actually makes it work
that has to be just pure out just divine
intervention look you all know device
he's a four-time major winner and has
more mvp awards than anyone can count at
this point and of course device is no
stranger to collaterals he's pulled off
some of the flashiest aces in recent
memory all while using one less bullet
than required device is even here to
help out and now
while it is good for one they give it
the respect to get back to the car that
might be their undoing the short play
now from twists oh device reads it in
with the flick burning alive and the
collateral in the flames but that isn't
our number one play no that honor can
only go to one special play the device
was in a 1v4 against arguably the best
team in the world at the time and all he
had was a deagle there's no way
right
inferno best of three i mean again there
are two best teams in the world right
now and
to get to a third map i just think it's
everything you could possibly want here
advice i don't know the bell is ringing
might be the train bell but certainly
ringing first round this right here one
versus four and he's going to get a head
shot oh oh what
no way
what makes us play even better is the
reaction from literally everyone on the
server it was so insane that vitality
couldn't help but crack a smile
alright clap kiddos that's our list if
you think you missed anything please let
us know down in the comment section
below take care and i'll see you in the
next one
[Music]
dude
what's going on what's pushing us to
spawn we're sandwiched
oh jet set i don't know if they know
about me
i might not know hold on